my name is Ryan Morris I am 29 managing
about 15 million dollars Warren has said
that he lives just like he makes 150
thousand dollars a year except for the
private jet other than that there before
the Berkshire meeting last year to pay
our respect to the great Church of
frugality we four guys who all worked at
hedge funds flew to Kansas which is
cheaper than Omaha and we got the
crappiest cheapest rental car we could
find to drive to Omaha all together and
then stayed in the crappiest hotel I've
ever been you go to these events where
they have free drinks and food and we
got it down to $48 night for the four of
us in the busiest weekend of the year in
Omaha but 11 years old I had this idea
that I really wanted to change the world
through science and my father introduced
this idea to me that you know Ryan even
if you're the best scientists in the
world you're not going to make a nuclear
fusion happen the guys with the capital
the one who make those kinds of
decisions and so that sort of flipped a
switch for me and I said okay well let's
look at Forbes 400 who's this guy
Buffett
I start reading his letters sounds very
deceptively simple you know I could do
that you know he's just this aw shucks
guy he just goes and pick stocks the
fact that it was accessible at all to a
twelve-year-old it was just amazing and
that goes to the power of how he can
communicate in a way that is very primal
and inaccessible Buffett says try to
choose your heroes wisely
he's been my hero since I was 12
Warren Buffett has set just about the
best example that any business person
ever has so it's not a huge impact